hello everybody and welcome to a brand
new video today I'm going to be showing
you how to find profitable items to haal
of course we'll go over some examples of
items that are generally good to do but
more importantly I'm going to show you
exactly how I find myself profitable
items or more more often times Break
Even items uh so you can haal without
actually breaking your bank and uh yeah
let's get started okay guys so we have
uh two Mill to start with and we're
going to see what items we can find to
Al for profit now I kind of divide this
up kind of the same way I do flips uh
some are high volume alks and some are
low volume alks now the uh Alchemy for
items like say the r plate body black
dragonhide those will generally be more
profitable or easier to find a break
even margin at least uh but they're kind
of punished by only having a limit of
like a 100 which is actually a pretty
big problem when you're Aline for magic
training say like you'll go through
hundreds every hour so you have to wait
on them for that long it can be a bit of
a hindrance uh whereas the uh high
margin or not high volume items say like
um oh the magic Sho people do a lot
Battle stabs those uh will be able to
buy a bunch and you won't be limited by
the LI the limit in the grand exchange
uh but it's a lot harder to find a
profitable margin on them uh so we'll
try a couple of uh each and yeah let's
get started so what we're going to do is
we're going to open up GE tracker which
is just a RuneScape uh tracking website
for the grand exchange uh link will be
in the description for that and we
already have an item open here the black
dehy body we're just kind of looking at
that and it has a nice little feature
here so it has all the information but
down here actually has the high ALK
profit and this is take into account the
cost of nature Rune which apparently is
251 uh so we'll go ahead and just check
that quickly of course you're going to
want to check it manually
here uh so
7925 and
7831 um so if we bought him for
731 I we'd be profiting actually six GP
after the cost of the nature Rune uh so
we'll definitely go ahead and buy some
of these um yeah 7831
and
uh let's get some magic train in here uh
we can just hit the limit I guess
125 I think is what the limit
is and next up we'll try a item with a
higher limit and see if we can find
one uh so all I do pretty much is I just
come here start searching up items so
like let's go for the battle staff now
obviously not items not all items will
work for this some items just have such
big discrepancy between what their High
Al value is and their price is so this
will never work this item will never be
profitable um we'll go over a fairly
larger list of items that might work in
a minute here uh but yeah so that that's
never going to work uh an item that
people do a lot is the magic
Longbow and the reason people do this is
because it will almost always have a
loss of about 100 which isn't terrible
and has a massive limit of 18,000 so
people can buy tons of these people who
aren't really interested in Saving too
much money will go for this Okay so
we've uh tried a couple items here now
we're going to try the Onyx bolt uh
Enchanted uh because this does seem to
have a pretty high ALK
value um let's uh where' it go let's
look it up again Onyx
bolt
e and um while it says we're going to
lose 48 has a high value of 9,000
let's have a look at what we're at
here so that looks promising
246 so we losing 5 GP but that is not
too bad in the grand scheme of things
here uh so we put an offer in for
8754 and uh well we're limited a bit by
cash here but we'll do 120 and uh yeah
oh no we will not do 120
115 okay guys we will come back when the
items have bought okay so we instantly
bought pretty much the Onyx P EAS right
away uh the black dragon hides um were
coming in pretty quick for a while other
kind of dropped off uh so we'll go ahead
and buy some nature runes with the cash
we have left and we Al them and we'll
see what our cash stack is like after
Okay so we're just finishing up our alks
we have three left and looks like we're
pretty much going to break even
uh which is not too bad considering most
of the items we bought were high volume
items like I could have bought 10,000 of
this item possibly for that price and
still been totally fine uh so that is
the power of buying items like the Onyx
bolt tips or items like the air battle
staff stuff like that uh it has a high
buying limit and it's going to be much
better for alen than let's say the black
dragon hi you saw didn't actually work
too well I could have waited an hour or
two and bought the full amount but
what's the point when you just want to
start training now and one thing I want
to go over just before I show you some
of the best items or items that are
generally good to Al one last thing uh
if you want to leave offers in overnight
there's an easy way to just kind of
calculate what the minimum price is you
should put it in uh so let's just open
up G tracker again and let's pop an item
in let's try the green dragonhide
body uh so we're going to come down here
and so it doesn't look like it's
profitable right now um but we'll take
the high Al value so
4680 and take off 252 roughly is the
price of a nature Rune so 4428 that is
what we have to buy it for uh to make
our money back and then we going to come
do is come down here I can see the
historical price and we'll just pop it
down to the most current and we'll look
is there an item or is there a price
where it's um below 4428 definitely
looks like pretty commonly it is
actually so yeah Green Dragon hides
would be a good offer to just leave in
overnight especially since it has a
limit of 125 just pop an offer in for
like 500 of those leave it in and you're
not at risk of ever losing any money at
worst you can just Al them all so yeah
there we go easy way to uh ensure that
you have profitable items and again you
can't really lose too much doing this
okay so now I'm going to go over a list
of items that I do pretty frequently
when I'm aling now of course these won't
always work it's a good place to get
started uh so battle stabs work quite
well all the elemental battle stabs are
aling for 9,300 sometimes you can get
them for under 9k uh which leads to 50
60 GP in profit uh trimmed armor is
pretty good cuz people will dump it uh
from clue Scrolls and stuff uh but it
still alks for the same price as regular
runite armor uh dragon height Armory and
saw works pretty well just happens to be
very close to the AL value and there's
tons traded in the game the only
drawback is the limit is generally 100
or roughly around that Onyx bolts and
like I did in the video very high limit
I actually was able to break even on an
item like that very good I don't think
any of the other bolts work very well
though armad zamra sodomin all that
armor same reason is you can snipe it
for pretty low and it still alks for the
regular Rune
value uh willow oak magic uh long bows
and short bows any Fletching equipment
can work pretty well uh but this is one
of the more popular items people do it
all the time and for good reason it has
very high limit and you can buy them in
bulk and they you generally will lose
money on these items but you won't lose
as much as just Aline lavaron or
something and uh lastly just Rune
equipment in general Rune daggers Rune
swords I mean you can find items uh that
will be very close to the AL value and
you can find some profitable items
within the runite category same with
Adamantite all armor Works decently well
but again is restricted by the buy and
limit and last of all if you are still
struggling to find profitable items to
Al um on the G tracker website if you
sign up for an account you'll have
access to this tool for two days uh it's
a high Alchemy tool it's going to show
you some profitable items uh that you
can buy to Al it's pretty useful um
again you have to take it with a bit of
a grain of salt these aren't going to
necessarily buy for this price but the
last recorded price was 5900 and this
High Al is right here it's pretty good
just for getting ideas even if you don't
do these top offers all the time I mean
I usually scroll down have a look for
cuz I'm generally interested in bulk
items more Air Battle stabs we did right
there but this is kind of where I got
the idea from and uh you can keep going
down the list and there's a bunch of
different ideas for you to find items uh
that could be profitable to Al all right
guys I hope you enjoyed the video if you
did don't forget to hit that subscribe
button uh to stay up to date with my
more recent videos and I will see you
guys next time
[Music]